okay what do i win
okay okay here we go all right
what movie does robert de niro's famous
line you talking to me
taxi driver correct where was aretha
franklin born
detroit memphis rydell high school is
the setting for which influential 70s
musical movie
greece correct how many total grammys
did aretha franklin win
oh boy eight eighteen
julie andrews won the best actress oscar
for which 1964 musical
sound amusing incorrect mary poppins
what song did aretha sing in the 1980
film the blues brothers
think correct jodie foster played fbi
agent clarice starling and what knight
silence of the lambs correct what was
the first feature animated movie
released in history
oh fantasia incorrect wait steamboat
really snowy
um what is your favorite aretha franklin
song
uh uh dr feel good
incorrect you're supposed to say respect
which 90s movie has the best selling
soundtrack of all time
oh the bodyguard correct what movie was
incorrectly
announced as the best picture winner
during the 89th oscars
oh yeah oh like
i don't remember yeah
tom hanks has been nominated for an
acting oscar six times what movie was
for his first one i don't know
philadelphia
big big really wow this is aretha
franklin lyric the moment i wake up
before i put on my makeup i
uh they sing a little song for you or
something like that
i have a little something and we are
done and i'm going to give you your
score
say a little prayer house
you